NARRATOR: At first
glance, this might
look like a very prolific
serial killer running out
of space for bodies.
Or perhaps an
overworked mortician
with too few crematoriums is in
the midst of the flu epidemic.
But thankfully, it's neither.
What you're looking at is a day
in the life of a Chinese sex
doll factory.
If you've ever seen
a sex doll before,
many thoughts probably
passed through your mind.
Who would use that?
How does it even work?
How much does it cost?
But one thought that probably
didn't make it through
was, I wonder who made that?
But like every product in this
world, someone had to make it.
Somebody set their
alarm, woke up,
went through their
morning routine,
and grumpily went to
their 9:00 to 5:00
job, which in this case,
was making sex dolls.
And this is the life of
many Chinese citizens.
Over 70% of all sex toys
sold around the world
come from China.
That means dildos,
vibrators, bondage gear,
and of course, sex dolls.
The factory where
these photos were taken
is the Ningbo Yamei plastic
toy factory in the Zhejiang
province of China.
They output 13 different
types of sex dolls,
and sell over 50,000
of them per year.
But these are on the cheap
end of the sex doll spectrum,
selling for an average of $16.
As technology has
advanced over time,
so has the realism and
price of sex dolls.
Customizable, life
like sex dolls
are now flooding the market.
Some come bald so the customers
can buy the wig they want.
Buyers can pick eye
color and breast size.
Some are now robotic that
can move on their own,
and talk to their human partner.
But of course, these
come with a price.
Instead of the $16
inflatable mate,
people are spending up to
$50,000 on their dream dolls.
Still, people are buying.
Chinese sex toys are a
multi-billion dollar industry.
They export them all
around the world,
sold both in stores and online.
You may even own one or two.
But remember, it
all started here
in a factory in a coastal
Chinese province made by people
just trying to make a living.
And for more videos, check
out the Seeker Daily episode
on the history of brothels.
LISSETTE PADILLA: So if
legal brothels really
did safeguard sex workers,
why were they outlawed?
The first real brothels that
accepted money in exchange
for sex were established in
Greece in the 5th century BCE.
NARRATOR: Thanks for watching.